okay today we are talking about the
number 10. uh do you know what
coincidentally it happens to be the 10th
anniversary of this channel so number
five has been going for 10 years we're
so proud of it and we thought it'd be
nice to return to the original location
of our very first video which was about
the number 11 and we came here to
nottingham forest football ground and we
sat in row 11 seat 11. we've just come
in through entrance 11 we walk this way
up here to row 11 and i'm going to sit
right here
in seat
number 11.
and today we're going to talk about the
number 10 sat in row 10 seat 10. to tell
you what's special about the number 10
i'm going to introduce you to something
called friendly numbers which sounds
nice doesn't it friendly numbers
not to be confused with amicable numbers
which we have talked about before a
classic number foul video this is
different although it starts off in the
same way because it's going to be about
the factors of a number and we're going
to add up those factors together so
let's do an example and let's do the
number 12 1 is always a factor and i'm
going to add these together so 2 is a
factor of 12 3
4 6 and 12 itself and if i add these
together i get 28 and what i'm
interested in is how big is that number
compared with the original number which
was 12. so if i'm comparing them one
thing i could do is i could divide that
sum
by its original number that's what i'm
going to do so 28 was the sum of factors
let's just divide that by the original
number 12. 28 divided by 12 i could
probably cancel that down i think that's
going to be 7 over 3. that's 2.333
going on forever so if i'm comparing the
sizes i'm saying that the sum of the
factors is over twice the original
number now this number will have a
friend
if there is another number that has the
same index we call this the index of the
number so let me give you an example of
a friend for 12
which is 234
so the factors for 234 is going to be a
little bit more difficult for me 1
always true 2 yeah it's even 3 to 6
9
plus 13 18
and 26
39
78 117
234 the original number okay
big sum what does that equal 546.
but if i look at the index which is that
sum
546 divided by the original number 234
we get
well a fraction that will cancel down it
will be seven thirds again it is the
same index as 12 they are friends oh
friends and if there's another number
that had the same index there would be
friends as well they perform a little
club together isn't that nice a little
team
this might start to sound a little
familiar
because it's very much like perfect
numbers and that's another classic
number foul video so we're going to talk
about the number
8128 and perfect numbers was the same
idea it took all the factors of the
number and you added them together let's
have a look at six what are the factors
of six i'm going to add them together so
1 plus 2 plus 3 and i'm going to add 6
itself
historically they didn't used to include
six itself and if i add up all those
other numbers you get the original
number back what i'm going to do today
is add all the factors together
including the original number and i'm
going to get 12. i get a number that is
twice
the original number and that's what a
perfect number is it has an index of two
so it's the exact same idea as friendly
numbers but friendly numbers don't have
to have an index of two
i've done before
try perfect numbers and that's when if
you add up all the factors it's three
times the original number so for any
numbers it's the same idea but it
doesn't have to be an integer so there
are currently 51 known perfect numbers
we think there's infinitely many of them
although we haven't actually proven that
but we found 51 of them which by the way
is four more than we knew of a decade
ago when number foul started here are my
questions do all numbers have a friend
and if the answer to that is yes do they
all have an infinite number of friends
very good question
no not all numbers have a friend so
there are some numbers that are solitary
we call them so if you don't have a
friend they're called solitary numbers
sometimes these friends are far apart
uh sometimes there's a huge gap between
friends i'll show you an example of that
i did need two pieces of paper
[Music]
so if we look at 24 let's do an index
i'm going to call it i for index index
of 24. so we're going to add up the
factors of 24. what's that going to be 1
plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus 6 plus 8 plus
12 plus 24 and if i add all that up it
is at 60 divided by 24 or if you wanted
to cancel that down it's it's 5 halves
so that's the index of 24. if you want
to find another number with the same
index five halves 2.5
you have to search quite a lot
so the next number with the same index
is 91 million
963
648
add up those factors divide by the
original number has the same index
there's going to be a lot of cancelling
down there but that's how far apart
these numbers can be
so solitary numbers well i don't know if
you'll be that surprised the primes
are solitary numbers i guess that kind
of makes sense it does to me so five is
a prime and this is the index of five
well the factors are five well there
aren't many it's one and five itself so
it's gonna be one plus five divided by
five uh six over five and that's the
index of five and there is no other
number with that same index and the
prime powers
are the same problem that means it's a
prime number squared or cubed or
something like that and i'll do an
example uh 25 is 5 squared as a prime
power if you look at the factors what we
got well it's not very much again it's 1
5 and 25 itself 31 over 25 there are no
other numbers with the same index and
what i want to point out
why is this true
notice these index that i did
they don't cancel down that is actually
something that's true in general so if
you look at an index for a number and if
it doesn't cancel down if it's
irreducible then it is a solitary number
that means that the sum of the factors
don't share any factors with the
original
number i can sort of tell you why that's
true
so what happens is if your number
doesn't share any factors with the sum
then it turns out that if you're looking
for another number with the same index
that number will have to be a multiple
of your original number the problem with
that is if it's a multiple of your
original number it has a larger index
not the same index and that's why it
doesn't exist so your number is going to
be solitary unfortunately that rule i've
just told you
isn't enough to find all the solitary
numbers
in fact there are solitary numbers that
break that rule 18 is an example of that
and we can do the factors okay so 1 plus
2 plus 3 plus 6 plus 9 plus 18 we'll
divide by 18 itself that is 39 over 18
and that does cancel down i think i'm
going to get 13 over 6. so it breaks
that rule but this number is solitary
and that's been proven by hand
so it actually turns out the same kind
of uh excuse us before if you look at 18
if you do the calculations by hand it
turns out that another number with the
same index has to be a multiple of 18
and if it is a multiple of 18 it has a
larger index
therefore it doesn't exist 18 is
solitary so now let me show you which
numbers are solitary and which ones are
friendly so the friendly numbers i've
marked out in blue here six is a perfect
number and we know that means it's
friendly and i've got 12 and 24 28 these
are friendly numbers they have a partner
they have friends uh the solitary
numbers are marked in green so your
primes prime powers uh and numbers that
don't share
factors with that sum
uh and i've also marked out some of the
special ones uh 18 45 48 52 they are
solitary but they're not prime they're
not prime powers they don't have that
special rule we've worked that out by
hand
but there are some numbers we don't know
the rest of these numbers here which are
marked in yellow we don't know if they
are friendly or solitary it's going to
be hard to work out it's actually a hard
problem and the smallest one we don't
know
is ten
ten ten we don't we don't know we don't
know if 10 has friends or not so we
don't know 10 has friends we've checked
numbers going to the trillions we
haven't found a friend for 10 yet
fine 10 a friend
what is ten's index oh we could work it
out so let's find a friend for ten
factors of ten one plus two is a factor
five plus ten we're dividing by ten so
what we're going to get eighteen divided
by ten one point eight we are looking
for a friend for ten it's going to have
an index of 1.8 but we haven't found it
yet maybe
10 is solitary and what i like about
this is that there are still mysteries
about
such a small humble number like the
number 10.
welcome to our first official video on
our new channel called number file 11 11
11.